I gotta say happy early Mother's Day
thank you how are you hoping to
celebrate your special day I mean it's
like a day off
well girl when you got all these
projects going on no I'm looking forward
to just spending it at home with the
kids and and watch the mother and the
hubby and watch the mother definitely be
going on in the house why not why not
what kind of wisdom do you hope they are
picking up from Mama oh God I you know I
just want them to
be whole healthy loving beings you know
what I mean who stand in their own truth
and unapologetically themselves I try to
do that
um and I've tried to do that more as
I've gotten older and grown up a bit and
I want them to you know know that
there's nothing that they can accomplish
that they are very that they are
Limitless that is a real thing if you
believe that you will be able to
accomplish anything in your life and and
I hope that they're getting that from me
wow that was very inspiring
we could just sit here all day and I
learned from her every day like she'd
say things like that and it was like now
what do I say you burn down our entire
world
for her yes you got a lot of skills girl
and you showing them off in this but it
is fueling this storyline as this mother
her love yes her Fierce desire to
protect her beautiful child you know so
how much could you relate to that
feeling in your own blended family well
obviously you know my kids were about
the same age as Lucy when we were
filming and it's relatable to everybody
everything that we were kind of going
through and the interactions that you
have with a kid at that age I think
that's one of the things about the
mother is that she's 12 when she meets
her you know because she gives her up
when she's an infant and never even gets
to hold her but that that interaction of
like dealing with a teenager well girl
you're living it right now yes and I was
living it then and so it was very you
kind of kind of cathartic to kind of
bring everything that was happening in
my life into the movie too and in that
something she's a bit of a helicopter
parent I guess you could say when she
gets her time to parent her child yeah
you and Ben are y'all helicopter parents
I don't know even know what that term
means over possessive
I wouldn't call myself a helicopter
parent you're more laid back I'm a
little more laid back yeah I'm a little
more laid back you know we're a little
bit gypsy-ish you know we've traveled
the world me and my kids you know I give
them their space you know I feel like
I'm here yeah I love you I do whatever
you need I do recall whenever I was
interviewing Emmy though over Zoom yes
you were off camera and I was like who
said you were took so yes yes good who's
a disciplinarian at the house oh I think
we both are yeah we both are but we're
gentle in in that way we're not
disciplinarians and like a really tough
aggressive way that's not our style yeah
I hate it here I want to go home not
till you know how to survive everything
it takes
well she was not gentle when y'all were
filming no I actually sometimes
sometimes I actually told her like I do
feel like you're about to hit me you
know like but she was so she's a very
tough person and then living out I think
in the wilderness for 12 years made her
even more closed off but then you know
doing these scenes with J.Lo out in the
snow and all the elements with the
garban what was that like for you
learning and working alongside this
woman I mean she and it everything made
it so real yeah that's and I think
that's something that I love about this
movie is that almost everything is real
like the snow is real the Landscapes you
know the whole vibe that I thought she
was about to you know hit me was real
the screams were so real everything is
something that you can relate to and
it's so real and the chemistry between
the two of you is so that was real from
here on you do everything I say
you're driving I'm 12. let's go now this
movie here this has given me major
enough Vibes remember you know but yeah
did you feel that way whenever you're
reading through the script for the very
first time and not when I read through
the script I didn't think about that
because this was really about a mother
and daughter and that was kind of about
an abusive relationship which is very
different and a woman going on the run
with her child who's small at the time
but this is this was very different this
playing like an assassin who you know is
an incredibly skilled uh sniper who's a
combat veteran who fell into the wrong
things and made some you know very
questionable choices for her life until
she gets pregnant and becomes a mom and
then that kind of changes everything and
she has to go into hiding and give up
her kid and it's it's it's a lot it's
and it's different than enough because
this is a like a huge action movie it is
so good JLo thank you you know you just
give me all the feels with shotgun
wedding marry me now we got a mother so
so good but what is it that you love
about playing a booty
I like that at this point in my career
that I've even offered a role like that
I don't think that would have happened
20 years ago you know and so you would
think I would get offered three like 20
or in my 20s or 30s but now that I get
I'm doing this at this time is really to
me kind of groundbreaking in a way you
know I haven't seen it we also see like
men in these type of roles kind of
protecting their family and protecting
their kids and you don't really see the
the mom doing that as much who's like
I'm super skilled right you know kind of
person I have a set of skills yeah you
know
[Music]
thank you